17 ans enfermé dans une cellule aveugle
au cameroun alors qu'il n'avait rien à
se reprocher michel atangana est un
français que son pays a oublié il a vécu
la plus longue détention arbitraires
effectuées à l'étranger
brimé maltraités il a même été privés
d'assistance consulaire pendant 12 ans
c'est pourtant un droit fondamental pour
tout ressortissant français
c'est très douloureux cgt enfermé dans
un sous-sol à la gendarmerie dans une
cellule de 7 mètres carrés
sans droits
j'y ai passé effectivement cette année
dans les années 90 michel atangana
travailler au cameroun auprès
d'entreprises françaises de concert avec
le pouvoir de paul biya
toujours président actuellement mais en
1997 il est arrêté accusé de rallier
l'opposant titus edzoa et denis une
parodie de justice le condamne alors à
une lourde peine de prison pour
détournement de fonds publics
un groupe de travail de l'onu reconnaît
en 2013 sa condition de victimes de
détentions arbitraires
finalement il est libéré sous
l'impulsion de françois hollande en 2014
et rapatrié en france
mais michel atangana n'est toujours pas
réhabiliter ses comptes bancaires sont
toujours bloqués une vie à la veille
tout ce qui a été fait par le cameroun à
mon endroit par la libération me donne
un statut de coupable et la france à
garder ce statut
dont je ne peux rien faire je ne peux
pas vivre je peux pas travailler durant
la détention de michel atangana
les ministres des affaires étrangères
qui se sont succédé n'ont rien fait
alain juppé et bernard kouchner ont
prétendu ne pas pouvoir s'ingérer dans
le processus judiciaire camerounais les
autorités françaises ne peuvent
interférer dans le fonctionnement de la
justice d'un pays tiers
le droit international proscrit toute
ingérence dans le fonctionnement de la
justice d'un état souverain
pendant que j'étais arrêté on a vu
l'état des interventions de la france la
france est allée dans le monde entier
mais dans mon cas il n'y a pas eu
d'intervention
en effet en 2009 par exemple bernard
kouchner n'avait pas hésité à exiger de
l'iran qu'il libère l'enseignante
clotilde reiss nous voulons nous
exigeons nous souhaitons même en plus au
plus vite sa libération il ya eu plus de
quarante courrier envoyé par les
soutiens divers tout a été fait pour que
la france intervienne mais en réalité il
ya eu
or au fus de soutien de protection
plusieurs voix interrogé sur cette
injustice le quai d'orsay n'a donné
aucune suite à nos questions laurent
bigot ancien diplomate sous directeur
pour l'afrique de l'ouest à l'époque
dénonce la situation michel thierry
atangana étant juste droit de se poser
la question qu'est ce qui fait que moi
je ne suis pas considéré comme un
citoyen à part entière et que je ne
puisse pas bénéficier de la protection
complète de l'état français alors oui
mais quand il se pose cette question il
se dit c'est peut-être parce que j'ai la
peau noire si on regarde le son parcours
ont bien l'état français a commis une
faute lourde
on ne l'assistant pas d'un point de vue
consulaires lorsqu'il a été incarcéré en
97 au cameroun état français prolongent
en fait sa faute lourde
on ne répare en pas son erreur
aujourd'hui il ya la même indifférence
qu'il y avait lorsqu'il était incarcéré
donc je pose la question où est l'état
où est l'humanité de l'état français
après eric dupond moretti
c'est aujourd'hui au tour de l'avocat
antoine v de défendre le dossier de
michel thierry atangana
on est face à un processus politique
diplomatique extrêmement bloquer la
france devrait à mon sens aussi prendre
sa part de responsabilité en invitant le
cameroun à reconnaître la situation tout
à fait exceptionnelle qui a été infligée
à michel thierry atangana et ce sont
donc des dialogues entre deux pays dont
on sait que parfois ils sont complexes
mais qui au regard de la situation
exceptionnelle devrait donner lieu à une
discussion rapide direct et surtout
pragmatique en vue de l'indemnisation de
monsieur atangana et de la
reconnaissance de son statut mais
aujourd'hui sept victimes de détentions
arbitraires se bat pour que cette
situation n'arrive pas à d'autres
il a inspiré un amendement dans le cadre
de l'actuelle réforme de la justice
adoptée à l'assemblée le 20 mai dernier
comme je te le vent souffle
j'ai vraiment pris conscience des
absences de la france pour certains
français dont j'ai décidé de participer
un meilleur accompagnement des français
en travaillant avec les députés dans
pire à l'heure à fond pour protéger les
français
si le processus arrive à son terme on
aura marqué un pas très important entre
1500 et 2500 français sont détenus à
l'étranger dont 500 sans cause connue et
deux millions et demi de français vivent
hors de l'hexagone qui pourrait un jour
devenir comme michel atangana les
victimes d'une détention arbitraire